what up reject Nation it's your girl salamander
AKA Sally Lamonica you can follow me on all
socials welcome back we are on Thor 2 the
Dark World I don't know anything about it
so I'm going into it with a fresh mind please
hit that like button if you do enjoy this
reaction at any point if I make you laugh
it would make you cry hopefully it'll make
you cry also please hit that subscribe button
if you're not already subscribed because I
don't know you like should be it's free and
not a lot of things in this world are free
I'm pretty sure in the dark world it's not
free to subscribe so see what I did there
if you want to watch my full reaction to this
movie you can go to the patreon of the real
rejects it's www.patreon.com the real rejects
Greg and John have a bunch of other really
fun full-length reactions and cool stuff for
you guys on that channel also we have merch
now there is real rejects merch I'm pretty
sure it's going to be in the link below get
you a hoodie or a beanie it really helps the
channel and quick shout out to prepper for
editing together these highlights y'all are
real ones I'm so excited all right we are
descending to the Chrome in three two ow I'm
such a dork and I hate it and this is why
I was in popular in high school
an ancient force of infinite destruction
Venom as the nine words could at last unleash
the ether
But as God ripped the weapon from his grasp
without it the dark elves fell
oh I hate that my ass that's creepy
shall we destroy it if only we could cook
One does not simply walk into more doors the
one will ever find it but someone's gonna
find it plot twist wherever you go there is
war ruin all this because low-key desires
it is my Birthright yeah Birthright what's
that guy
who spend the rest of your days in the dungeon
forever why do I still feel bad for Loki
there he is I've got this completely under
control is that why everything's on fire that's
cause a girl was leading it of course everything's
gonna be on fire have you seen our emotions
all yours I'd love to see him in the hall
fight I accept your surrender [Applause]
[Music] you are ready time has come for you
to take the throat Embrace and celebrate what
you've won at least pretend to enjoy yourself
oh he misses her boy she misses you too don't
even worry about it you know that scientific
equipment you're gonna look at anymore you
might want to start looking at it again this
is the reason we came all the way out here
kind of looks like the readings that Eric
was rambling about I want banana balls he's
not interested I'm not interested harmless
Rambler approached the area then decided to
strip naked and effectively terrorize tourists
there with scientific equipment while shouting
that he was trying to save them the man later
identified as noted astrophysicist oh no oh
they're kids are you the police no we're a
scientists well I am
where'd it go
Sometimes they come back sometimes they don't
I was gonna be like jump now I'm like no
car keys why would you do that
what it's like the upside down
what
I knew it I was like is he gonna say it has
awoken but he's had something similar how
do they always know they're always sleeping
and it's always like it's like that's a raven
they just know how was she clever your motor
she doesn't know it yet but she studies the
convergence as well even
what
hmm where the hell were you tell me you didn't
call the police you were gone for five hours
what that's weird
whoa
oh my God he's there imagine waking up from
a nap and he's just standing there and you're
like oh my God that's cool you said you were
coming back I know I know but the bifrost
was destroyed the nine Realms erupted to the
chaos wards where raging Marauders were pillaging
I had to put an end of the slaughter imagine
that's what your boyfriend sends you after
ghosting you the realms his private property
and your trespassing a lot of them you have
to come with me this woman has done well she's
dangerous so am I hold on to me what are you
doing go into space
oh [__]
I would vomit probably [Laughter] I don't
know whether to laugh
the infection defending born of Eternal knife
the dark elves come to steal away the light
made a weapon out of that darkness and it
was called The Ether The Ether is fluid and
ever-changing it changes matter into dark
matter it seeks out host bodies drawing strength
from their life force malakive sought to use
the ether's power to turn the universe their
masks are so creepy does your book happen
to mention how to get it out of me no has
no one asked her like how it got in her yet
a true king admits his faults what if the
lives you took on Earth I mean a handful compared
to the number that Odin has taken himself
your father he's not my father
three five thousand years the world's aligned
perfectly the borders between worlds become
blood it's possible you found one of these
points once the world's pass out of the moment
when the connection is lost she just so happened
to fall through a portal to happen to be where
the ether is or they're supposedly supposed
to have buried it so no one would find it
foreign
[Music]
you might want to take the stairs to the left
what
nothing severe you've never been a very good
liar take it to your Chambers I'll come for
you when it's safe she's like she's leopard
dang what is this dagger made out of
what
day good job Idris Elba
wow
[Music] everybody 's gonna get through
[Music]
how did he know where that was
foreign
which so sorry
where is these I'll never tell I believe you
no
[Applause]
dude she was badass I'm sad
[Music] and the last thing Loki said to her
was you're not my mother oh my God
I'm having a moment
I hope Loki gets revenge because he's gonna
feel really guilty [Music]
I don't know about her I'd be feeling real
upset that Thor's mom got killed by protecting
me because I'm an idiot and touched thing
I don't know I would feel so guilty you should
too we better fight the last house Guardian
breath the last drop of us got in blood and
how are you different from Malika the difference
my son is that I will win
he being mad
we must move Jane off world my Frost has been
shut down and the Tesseract locked away in
the vault there are other parts of ashgard
ing to a few one actually
oh
have you come to gloat you're enough no more
illusions
[Music] thank God
I know you seek Vengeance as much as I do
you helped me escape as God and I will granted
to you
you must be truly desperate
know that when we fought each other in the
past I did so with a glimmer of hope that
my brother must have been there somewhere
that hope no longer exists to protect you
you betrayed me and I will kill you
hmm Brother you look ravishing it will hurt
no less when I kill you in this form perhaps
you prefer one of your new companions given
that you seem to like them so much oh this
is much better
feel the righteousness surging hey wanna have
a rousing discussion about truth honor patriotism
God bless him [Laughter] he's loving this
it's so good yeah I'm Loki that was for New
York I like her
well whatever you're doing brother I suggest
you do it faster shut up looky
must have missed something I didn't I'm pressing
every button on this thing laughs
foreign
now they're following us
well done you just decapitated your grandfather
let's steal the biggest most obvious ship
in the universe and escaping that it's truly
brilliant
laughs I see your time in the dungeons has
made you no less graceful Loki okay I was
like how are you gonna get there in the water
everyone would do it are you mad possibly
foreign
Josh
get your hand on me and Josh
but I thought you still wanted to kill that
as Guardians because you hate them you think
you alone were loved a mother you had her
tricks but I had her trust trust we let her
die what help were you and yourself who put
me that who brought me that you looked down
the world
you wouldn't want us to fight
or she wouldn't exactly be shocked
look
where'd they go
still don't trust me brother would you
no I wouldn't what
whoa
damn she's tripping [Music] now
wow
wait what [Music]
ah
yeah you smell completely horrible that twist
though okay I'm here for it I liked that
[Music] no no no no no no
okay good
job Dora
oh
um
that'll do it
no
see you in hell monster [Music]
[Applause]
I'm sorry I'm sorry
it's all right I'll tell father what you did
here today no I like Mommy I didn't do it
for him
God damn it
I don't want to watch these anymore I saw
him on Earth why would he go to Earth
none of this would have happened if I hadn't
found the answer would have only possessed
that much sooner
this is why you don't chase after men
destroy the planet I would be a little more
upset that your brother just died Thor oh
my God I was just wondering if you want to
try again uh maybe dinner next time oh yeah
yeah yeah oh my God
oh those are the keys so who's Richard really
oh this movie malachith is going to fire The
Ether at a spot where all the nine worlds
are connecting yeah so the alignment is only
temporary he must be in exactly the right
place at the right time well how do we know
where that is follow the directions
foreign
your world and your family will be extinguished
uh
it is awesome how did you do that well gravitational
fields interact with the weak spots between
worlds creating right get the guy with the
sword
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music] that's crazy
what
this Amber was like nope
oh
that noise killed me
they're like standing inside you just hear
oh
oh man they got me wow
oh my God
she's okay
go Ian do something heroic yes [Applause]
you saved my life yes I did KSM
[Laughter] how do I get to Greenwich take
the strain three stops
[Music] that's crazy you're telling no one
else notices that those things stopping you
not from here we can't get close enough
he needs some goggles I've come to accept
your surrender
[Music]
the evil cannot be destroyed but you can
where did he go
that's lucky
I'd rather be a good man than a great king
is this my son I hear or the woman he loves
um this is not for Jane father now forbid
me to see her or say she can rule on my side
it changes nothing one son who wanted the
throne too much another who will not take
it I cannot give you my blessing nor can I
wish you good fortune if I were proud of the
man my son had become even that I could not
say go my son
thank you Father
no thank you what
oh I was wondering why they didn't spend more
time on the grief of his death and oh my God
what
I almost cried over you okay
I'm gonna skip to the end credits now
Let's uh skip on down
Loki needs to stop playing games man
here's Thunder
oh no oh
my God Thor will return well that was Thor
the Dark World listen guys I didn't hate it
as much as I thought I would pissed off other
people saying it was like one of the worst
ones I would say I really enjoyed the second
half way more than I enjoyed the first half
I feel like it kind of reminded me of watching
a show there was lots of repetitive scenes
I don't know if it was just me that noticed
that like they showed the scientists running
around naked like twice um I feel like that
could have just been one they basically kept
having the same conversations over and over
I was like is this risky what do we do and
then also like oh let's tell the story I told
you as a kid but it was true stuff like that
I feel like it could have been condensed a
little bit they didn't really give the audience
the benefit of the doubt with that one because
they already explained in the beginning I
was like okay cool I get it you're setting
up the villain now oh this thing happened
a long time ago and you need to know this
information because it comes back later you
know these people come back for Revenge I
get that there was just a lot of repetitive
conversations so I can understand why people
thought this movie was slow only because like
the first half of it kind of felt like that
I feel like a show where they were spending
a little more time I felt like I watched like
three episodes of like kidnap book show or
something but I definitely enjoyed seeing
Jane's character a lot more in this movie
because she got a lot of moments in this movie
to shine grieving over two characters in one
movie it was a lot but I I understand why
they did that and I was so upset when she
died she's such an amazing actress the mother
I thought her performance when she had that
really heart-wrenching argument was low-key
it was just awful she did such a good job
with that because then with her death it like
really showed some weight I feel like though
in terms of Jane and Thor I don't think it
lingered a lot on their grief at all of like
anything and I kind of wish it did this could
have been way darker with I don't know maybe
diving into Thor's just it's kind of again
reminding me of like Spider-Man 2 when he's
like I don't even think this is something
I want to do anymore because it's just hurting
people around me and I think that would be
so brilliant because it really delves deep
into the characters constant battle within
himself of is this the responsibility that
I really want and I feel like by the end of
it went Thor's like I don't want to be king
I feel like it would have been more impactful
if you really you saw him really mentally
struggle after the death of his mom and then
after the death of his brother like he should
have been out for the count like mentally
just a wreck right but then there was just
a lot of humor which I loved all the humor
in this movie but something about it didn't
seem very human to me to just jump from both
of those and then but then you see Loki at
them that kind of pissed me off it kind of
pissed me off another twist I get it but like
they should have ended it there and I feel
like the twist maybe could have been I'm mad
I don't know that was a lot that was a lot
I I'm processing a lot would have been more
powerful if you walked away from the movie
being like Loki's dad holy [__] you know
because then if you came back later I don't
know anything about the rest of the movie
is really but I know there's another Avengers
like let's say he came back then you'd be
like what the [__] bro explain but it
would have held more weight I just want things
to hold more weight with these Marvel movies
man I do like the amount of time they spent
um on the mom's you know passing that that
got me like that was impactful I had tears
in my eyes but yeah I just kind of wanted
to see more of Thor really struggling with
himself with this movie and it didn't really
happen I wanted to see that struggle as the
character but um I I just still really enjoyed
watching the characters I I enjoyed these
characters a lot and that little Cameo from
Captain America killed me oh my God that was
really great that was really great I think
that Chris Hemsworth and Tom Hiddleston play
off each other so well I love seeing their
Dynamic together which is why I was so upset
at the end um the villain to me wasn't the
most interesting part of the movie to be honest
because you're kind of just like okay how's
Anna kill this guy and then it was kind of
Lucky it was just luck basically they tell
them if you really think about it and then
everything falling that was a cool fight sequence
you know them just falling through different
Realms that was pretty sick and made me laugh
a lot I really enjoyed watching that fight
sequence because it was unique in that sense
I've never seen a fighting games like that
before but yeah the villain wasn't super interesting
to me in this movie and I feel like his motivation
was just I don't know it was pretty one-dimensional
to me but um overall the I don't know the
fighting and the effects and everything were
super sick in this movie like so many different
aircrafts and ships and and weapons and I
just thought the the visual effects in this
movie were like amazing um I I really enjoyed
watching just all the different like I could
watch a show of all these characters is what
I'm getting at like this I could watch more
of this not just as a movie I could totally
like see like an Asgard show or something
and I would be I would be into it because
this was like a mixture of like Lord of the
Rings in Star Wars that's kind of in like
a little bit of Narnia I don't know that's
what I was thinking all throughout which is
awesome and you really got to see a lot more
of Kat Dennings character in this movie as
well and she's hilarious again kind of the
every man character which I I would want to
play a role like that so bad it'll be so fun
to be the comedic relief in a movie like that
I don't know anything about the comics and
in the comments you can let me know is that
in the comics that Jane ends up getting the
was it called The Ether I just like accidentally
falling through into another realm and then
like seeing it and like being like what is
that that seemed a little far-fetched to me
it would have been cooler if it happen a different
way I feel like but I don't know if that was
in the comics if that's how it happened in
the comics when I think they buried it and
like didn't want anyone to find it I don't
think it'd be that easy it was my point of
like someone just fell through and like there
it is and it just happened to me Jane I don't
know but it was fun to see all that go down
and I really loved the twist when you think
that low-key top door's arm off and was betraying
his brother that was so good I wanted to laugh
and then I didn't because then I got real
but like it's so funny to me because the villains
are just standing there and there's kind of
like you know I can just see it from like
an outside perspective they're just in there
and they're like I'll do their fighting right
now like I was gonna see what's going on and
like they just they want it in on the T right
they was like what what's the tea with the
situation let's go take a closer look on the
drama you know and then obviously it was part
of their plan but I just think it's funny
they were just like yeah let's go over there
and watch them like beat each other that was
super fun I really I had fun watching this
movie it didn't take itself too seriously
but I feel like some of the moments were deep
enough that you're you know I was really into
it if I were to re-watch this movie I'd probably
just watch like the second half of it that's
probably where other people were coming from
with it and in terms of it being a little
slow in the first half but overall this was
such a ride guys this one had my emotions
all over the place more so than I think any
of the Marvel movies so far so I'm excited
to see the rest because if this is people's
like on you know on the lower end I can't
imagine what's gonna happen next in the future
movies so I'm super stoked also to see Robert
Downey Jr again and see them all interact
again and another Avengers movie with Thor
and everyone I guess Loki's back so I don't
know what he's gonna do but yeah this was
a ride thanks so much for delving Into the
Dark World with me I can't say that normally
I don't know why and yeah again give this
movie A like hit subscribe and the next one's
going to be Guardians no the neck and the
next one is going to be Captain America Winter
Soldier which I have heard nothing but good
things about I'm so excited to watch that
movie so see you next week bye [Music]